q a segment you guys ask questions uh
and we give answers to the best of our
abilities so i've got a question
from kevin
uh we've got a scenario on vacation not
doing structured exercise
how bad could weight gain slash muscle
loss be
if i act like a degenerate for two weeks
um
and so there's basically two questions
here uh talking about a two week time
frame muscle loss and also
weight gain or specifically fat gain if
it's happening in the context of muscle
loss
when it comes to the muscle loss
one to two weeks really is not a big
deal a
significant appreciable muscle loss
really shouldn't occur
over that one to two week time frame
uh as long as you're not like
immobilized or on complete bed rest uh
you know if you're going about your
day-to-day activities
one to two weeks is not a timeline that
i would be super concerned about uh
once we start getting to the like two to
three three to four week time frame then
i start to say okay now we might want to
talk about some pretty uh proactive
mitigation strategies to to make sure
that we're maintaining as much muscle
mass as we can
uh so what might that strategy be
not just over feeding protein uh the
research is pretty consistent
just bumping up your protein over a
vacation if you're not actually loading
your muscles
is not going to save you from muscle
loss
[Music]
if anything your protein needs could
potentially be a little bit lower since
you're not training but usually i just
try to keep my protein pretty stable in
this type of scenario there are some
studies indicating that like really high
dose leucine might be slightly helpful
uh but i wouldn't hold my breath on that
one uh the evidence is mixed the effect
sizes are not particularly large so uh
the strategy really isn't dieting in
this in this scenario when it comes to
retaining muscle uh if you're talking
about you know three four weeks or
longer uh it's important to recognize a
little bit of resistance training goes a
very long way we're talking about body
weight stuff if you can sneak a couple
bands in your travel bag
very basic stuff even if you don't have
gym access should go a very long way and
it doesn't have to be high volume if you
keep the intensity up you know either
doing high loads if they're ver if
they're available or just pushing
relatively close to failure with body
weight and band type stuff you don't
have to spend two hours a day doing this
stuff low volume but putting in the
effort uh should be a good way to go
when it comes to fat gain uh
i mean
to to gain a a considerable amount of
fat like if you're trying to gain a
kilogram of fat assuming that there's no
adaptive increase in total daily energy
expenditure from overfeeding and there
very well might be orders from being on
vacation and walking around doing
vacation stuff yeah so your total daily
energy expenditure very well could go up
in this uh situation but even if it
didn't we're talking about over 9000
calories of a surplus to store a new
kilogram of fat
um
so i mean if you're going way overboard
with your caloric intake i mean no doubt
some degree of fat accumulation can
occur
but it's nothing that can't be undone uh
after the vacation's over and the
likelihood of you know several kilograms
of fat mass gain uh quite implausible
within this type of time frame um so my
typical guidance uh
by the way your weight will likely
fluctuate quite a bit uh especially if
you're you're kind of really exploring a
lot of different food options and
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that eating is one of my favorite things
about vacations
but there's a lot of water weight
fluctuation
you know changing your food schedule
changing your food environment different
amount of just bulk material in the gi
tract different amount of sodium and
carbohydrate a lot of water fluctuations
but uh you know in terms of fat gain
probably not too much uh accumulation
there my typical guidance though uh when
i work with one-on-one clients who are
about to go on a one or two week trip
we basically set a spectrum with two
anchors uh so on one end of the spectrum
the really strict end of the spectrum we
say oh let's keep our diet exactly the
same no accommodations hit the same
targets weigh things the same way you
normally do or track things the same way
you normally do no change at all the
other end of the spectrum is
we're not just going off the diet we are
intentionally
aggressively indulging you know we are
really
just exploring every culinary option
and just
over feeding on a very consistent basis
um no targets no tracking no moderation
you know
if there's a hedonic occasion to eat
go for it you know past the point of
fullness now we rarely choose either of
those options that sets the spectrum and
then we talk about a variety of
different options that fall between
those ends of the spectrum so
we could
keep macro targets as a strategy but we
could increase the targets from where
they're currently at we could keep a
calorie target and a protein minimum but
say hey as long as you're kind of close
to these calories and getting at least
this much protein you're good to go we
could not track at all but say hey focus
on
you know food selection and meal
composition so when you sit down for a
meal where's my protein where's my
fibrous vegetable arrange a plate and
kind of focus on it that way one thing
i'll do
is i'll say pick one meal per day where
we're really going to loosen up so you
know keep things pretty uh pretty tight
with breakfast and lunch and then dinner
will be the big meal where we really
relax a little bit
a similar strategy prioritize the areas
where you want to indulge right so if
you want to go out for drinks one night
you know if i'm on vacation trying to be
mindful of my diet i'll say you know
what tonight i am having a few alcoholic
beverages so i might keep my entree you
know a little bit leaner you know go
with
lean you know fish and vegetables and
maybe a little starch and then save up
some calories so that i can have a
little more alcohol or you know you
could say i'm gonna
go a little lighter on the entree
because i really like a dessert that i
have my eye on or vice versa i'm gonna
skip dessert because i you know see this
particular entree that has caught my eye
so
there are a tremendous number of dietary
strategies that you could choose ranging
from very restrictive to very flexible
and what i do with my clients is i talk
through a pretty broad variety of these
and we figure out based on the context
of the trip what would be the most
sensible solution